of course as much as everyone wanted to
see what the
statue looked like all eyes were on
william and harry and their body
chemistry
and how they were interacting with each
other so as they
arrived at the sunken garden at
kensington palace they were walking
side by side and they were engaged in a
conversation
i watched it and thought how comfortable
they looked in each other's company
there wasn't any sign of
of any tension now i think both of them
have wanted today to be about the statue
about remembering diana's legacy and not
about
the rift that has really overshadowed
the coverage of the royal family for the
past 18 months now so
they clearly went to a lot of effort to
deflect from this rift
between the two of them and instead to
project on
their mother a legacy and crucially
putting on a united front to remember
diana
their mother on what would have been her
60th birthday
well this has been a very highly
anticipated reunion because of course it
is the first time that we've seen
the brothers on their own since
the fallout since mexic
and yes we saw them at the duke of
edinburgh's funeral and there was
a brief moment where they walked
together up to chapel hill as they made
their way
from the church up to the castle but
really
the focus was very much on william and
harry today
harry himself has said that he wants to
repair relationships with his family he
said that he loves his brother
and and he acknowledges that it's going
to take time
for the relationship to heal but i think
the end game
is the hope that it will heal it is
going to take some time the duke of
cambridge is still
very bitter and very hurt by a loss of
what harry and megan said in that
interview
particularly those allegations of racism
that were leveled against the royal
family
so clearly it's going to take far more
than the funeral of their grandfather
and indeed the unveiling of this statue
i think for the relationship to be
anywhere near what it once was and
possibly it's ambitious
to expect that it ever will be but i
think they both recognize
that a fracture that divides key and
important members of the royal family
is something that can only be ultimately
damaging
to the monarchy
while the unveiling of the statue isn't
going to be the
the ending of this rift and the complete
healing process between william and
harry
it does feel like a step in the right
direction
the fact that there wasn't any real
visible tension between them
um yes they were pushing on a good show
but it did feel
like a more positive step forward but i
think we're talking baby steps
and you know we are still quite a way
off
from healing this rift and both brothers
being able to move on from it
well we've very much seen kate sort of
step into that role of peacemaker
between the brothers she's very very
fond of harry but of course she's hugely
loyal to
her husband and their family we weren't
sure whether to expect the duchess today
i think the fact that she wasn't there
is reflective of william and harry
really wanting to
take control of their mother's legacy of
being the ones to have commissioned this
statue
and really wanting to make it an
intimate family affair which is what
they did
certainly behind the scenes kate's been
trying very hard to forge
a rapprochement between the brothers
[Applause]
my understanding is that harry is
understandably in a hurry to get back
home of course he's got
a one-month-old baby waiting for him his
family waiting for him so
i don't expect that he's going to stick
around too long
in the uk he's he's going to want to get
back home and that probably means
he won't have had time for a meeting
with his father the prince of wales
who's currently on official engagements
up in scotland at the moment it's it's
very hard to know exactly when the royal
family will get to meet
um archie who they have not seen for
over 18 months i mean we understand that
cambridges have have only seen archie
once or twice in his life and of course
none of the royal family have met lily
diana so
i'm sure that all of the family are
desperate to meet
these new additions harry initially left
start a new life
overseas his vision his intention
was that he would come back they would
enjoy holidays here
but obviously circumstances have changed
the rift between the brothers
is it does run deep harry's got a very
complicated
and difficult relationship with his
father right now so i think the idea of
cozy christmases at sandringham are some
way off
you